( music playing )
Hello, I'm Gav.
Welcome to
"The Super Slow Show."
Dan is currently getting
his wrist looked at
after he fractured it.
And I thought,
what can I do on my own?
So I decided to make
the cutest video
I could possibly make.
Up in our little
green viewing room
are six kittens
and two phantom cameras.
Hope you enjoy
the following montage
of lovely, fluffy,
soft, 4K kittens.
I'll see you up there.
( grunting )
I'd also like to thank
Heaven On Earth Society
For Animals
for lending us these kittens
and making sure they
stay safe amongst
the film crew.
( music playing )
Gav: Aw, look at you.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed
that incredibly cute video.
I'm gonna keep this one.
I think I'm gonna name him Dan.
Isn't that right?
Aw, it's all right.
Feel free to subscribe
to the "The Slow Mo Guys"
and we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
- ( kissing sound )
- ( music playing )
Hi guys, click here
to catch up on our
latest adventures.
I barely survived,
so I hope you like 'em.
Dan did complain a lot.
Then again, I do
all the work.
Most of it.
You do 90%.
- I do all the work.
- All right, fine.